guys blessings hating on me right now he
doesn't no I wanna I wanna do it here
this is the right spot
it's some kind of sucks the coffee talks
are not about the background it's about
the message
guys blessings hating on me for no
reason he's he's uh he's uh what do you
call it
um a
a modern producer
he's a modern producer he just you give
him the credit card a couple times but
he can't go down in quality and
lifestyle sometimes I just want to do a
video on my phone
um what do you have to say for yourself
plus blessings
he doesn't like the quality but I think
you guys like it it's like a direct
window to me okay now what are we
talking about today today I'm in Vegas
Sunny very nice I'm looking at a pool
right now you guys can't see it
um today I want to talk about going on
the whatever podcast
and I went on with um
Brian
that's the same right Brian okay I'm
sorry Brian look at like I'm not good
with names anyone that knows me now
on the show all these girls are going
around saying their body counts they're
saying what they've done on only fans
they're they're like it's so crazy and
these girls
are talking about
this and they also talked about the
mental issues that have come with the
doing only fast
so they're going around
and they're saying
is this all signed up yeah that is thank
you and so they're going around and this
one girl says she's on antidepressants
so I out of the kindness of my heart
offer her a solution I say maybe maybe
you call me crazy if you weren't on only
fans you might not be on antidepressants
and I was watching back this clip
and another girl
mentioned something that I didn't quite
catch at the time she said
well I'm sure
if she wasn't on only fans and making
70k a month
then she would be more depressed so
we're in a society where women think
money is more important than values
money like these are the quality of
wives that the men are getting these are
young 21 22. oh it oh I didn't sign did
I sorry sorry
these are men getting young 21 22.
um
I'm gonna give her a 50 tip I just liked
her
yes I'm gonna spend extravagantly today
all right 52.
I'm just feeling that she seemed like a
sweetheart
okay
these are the quality of the wives the
men are getting okay and so when the men
come in and say look
the women are homes the women are this
the women are that can we really blame
them
can we really did you hear them on the
panel when she said she slept with 200
dudes yeah
crazy do you think someone will marry
her
I feel like there's always a stamp
but and me and when I when I offer a
solution I was the only one offering
Solutions at that table there was
another lady on the table saying well we
don't have to judge I'm not saying that
I'm not saying that you won't find
anybody
I am saying that you won't find anybody
other than a Sim because anybody that
signs up for that is a low quality guy
I'm sorry if he's either he might not be
low quality and looks or money but he's
certainly low quality in his mentality
because any guy with his head screwed on
straight isn't going to tolerate that
and this is the problem where we start
to
change what is valuable in society we
start to say that things like money is
more important than value so when really
values are the only thing that matters
now I'm not saying that to go date
homeless men I don't know who would do
that
um but but
what I am saying is
people's character and their values are
important
um
we live in a society where
women want to do whatever we want and
have no consequences or repercussions
and they're gonna shoot the messenger
and say I'm unhappy judge it because the
whole show they were just implying that
I'm unhappy judgmental
um that I'm just a bad person because I
call
I call a spade a spade right I'm not
blind and I really think if we really
want to be kind to these only fans women
it's it's more important that we tell
them the truth and the truth is you're
going to have a really hard time on
doing all the damage you did you
probably can undo it but you know all
you can do in life is try you can't
change anything
um so maybe we should move in the right
direction and take down the only fans
but for some reason I'm the best am I a
bad guy for saying this blessing
and it's like the The Other Women
that'll call me judgmental or unhappy or
whatever
will
they'll say these things but yet I'm the
only one get I'm giving them practical
Solutions
what else did I want to rant about today
maybe nothing maybe I'm done
oh oh
how so this girl slept with 200 people
okay and I was gonna equate this
sleeping with 200 people is the
equivalent of those kids around I'm not
trying to talk about this too loud I'm
gonna
um
I'm doing I'll say doing that for for
you know pool pool safety doing now with
200 people is the equivalent of drinking
alcohol every day your your mind is
going to adapt because you can't fall in
love with everyone
otherwise you're gonna be heartbroken
like if you've never drank before and
you take two shots
you're hammered you're gone you're look
it and if you've never been with anyone
before
if you've never done that
and you're with someone you're in love
with that man for life there's no you're
never leaving the dude
um but you're mine and your body adapts
to the choices you make and you can't
blame men
for saying you know I'm good on this
it's not judgmental and it's not me and
it's actually
the kids are getting the floaties
it's actually very kind to me but nobody
look at nobody nobody sees it that way
anyways guys let me know maybe I'm crazy
maybe I'm just a big meanie I'm just the
rudest most awful
but let me know in the comments all
right like the video
subscribe to the channel bring that
notification Bell
enjoy your coffee guys